I am 50 years old and do you know what I don't want to do on my vacations anymore? Oh probably a few things. I don't want to cram my family into the same one bedroom room and bathroom. I don't want to. No. I don't want us all on top of each other. I want my own bedroom separate from the children, which is why I prefer Airbnb. Because we can all have our space, and then it's like, makes the whole vacation more relaxing. We can go to bed at different times. You know, I can stay up and read,
我今年 50 岁了，你知道我度假时最不想做的事是什么吗？哦，大概有那么几件。我不想把一家老小塞进同一个只有一间卧室和一个浴室的房间里。我不想。不。我不想让我们所有人都挤在一起。我想要有别于孩子们的自己的卧室，这就是为什么我更喜欢 Airbnb。因为我们都可以拥有自己的空间，然后这就好像是，让整个假期更加放松。我们可以不同时间睡觉。你知道的，我可以熬夜看书，
or more likely these days, I go to bed before everybody else. You know what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have a fridge, you have a kitchen. So I'm not calling up room service constantly and having to pay that fee.
或者现在的更有可能情况是，我在其他所有人之前就睡着了。你知道我最喜欢 Airbnb 的什么吗？什么？零食。你知道我最喜欢 Airbnb 的什么吗？什么？零食。你有一个冰箱，你有一个厨房。所以我不用经常打电话叫客房服务还要支付那笔费用。
I'm just like, hey, we pack snacks, they're in the fridge, go get them. Well, everyone, consider Airbnb for your next adventure. You won't regret making the switch from a traditional hotel. Get groceries delivered across the GTA from real Canadian superstore with PC Express. Shop online for super prices and super savings. Try it today and get up to $75 in PC optimum points.
我只会觉得，嘿，我们带了零食，它们就在冰箱里，去拿吧。好了，各位，请为您的下一次冒险考虑 Airbnb。从传统酒店转向 Airbnb，您绝对不会后悔。使用 PC Express，从真正的加拿大超级市场订购杂货并配送至整个 GTA 地区。网购可享超值价格和超大优惠。今天就来尝试，最高可获得价值 75 美元的 PC optimum 积分。
Visit superstore.ca to get started. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind-the-scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0.
访问 superstore.ca 即可开始。我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量的 VFF 故事，更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妈 6.0 版。
Hello. Hi. Happy New Year. It's 2025. Woohoo. Woohoo. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hi. Happy New Year. It's 2025. Woohoo. Woohoo.
你好。嗨。新年快乐。现在是 2025 年。呜呼。呜呼。我们是办公室辣妈 6.0 版。你好。嗨。新年快乐。现在是 2025 年。呜呼。呜呼。
We did it. We all made it through the holidays. We have a fun episode today. I was so excited in prepping this. I got really excited. Lady, I even stood up, I paced, I said things out loud. Really? Oh, should we tell people what we're doing?
我们成功了。我们都顺利度过了假期。我们今天有一期有趣的节目。我在准备这一期时太兴奋了。我真的变得非常兴奋。天哪，我甚至站了起来，我踱步，我大声说出了想法。真的吗？哦，我们应该告诉大家我们在做什么吗？
Yes. All right, the inspiration for today's episode comes straight from the Office fandom. You know, we have been digging online and we have found a lot of Office fan theories. You name it, you guys all have an origin idea about something on the show. So based on one of the most popular fan theories that you shared with us,
是的。好吧，今天节目的灵感直接来自《办公室》的粉丝群体。你知道的，我们一直在网上深入挖掘，我们发现了很多《办公室》的粉丝理论。你能说得出来的，你们所有人对剧中的某些事情都有一个起源的想法。所以基于你们与我们分享的最受欢迎的粉丝理论之一，
we're going to do a little detective work. Yes. A little mom detective work. Mm-hmm. Jenna, what are we mom detective-ing? Detectiving? There it is. Yeah.
我们要进行一点侦探工作。是的。一点妈妈侦探工作。嗯哼。珍娜，我们在进行什么妈妈侦探工作？侦探中？这不就来了。是的。
Today, we are finally tackling the question, is Toby the Scranton Strangler? Yes. And we asked you to write in and give us your theories and opinions. Thank you so much, by the way. They were amazing. Detailed.
今天，我们终于要探讨这个问题了，托比是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔吗？是的。我们邀请你们写信给我们，留下你们的理论和观点。顺便说一句，非常感谢你们。它们太棒了。细节丰富。
Yeah. I mean, really good stuff. Our producer Ainsley divided your letters into two sections. Those of you who think Toby is the Scran Strangler and those of you who think he isn't. So here's what we're gonna do. We are gonna have a good old fashioned debate using your letters to support our arguments.
是的。我的意思是，非常棒的内容。我们的制作人艾恩斯利将你们的信件分成了两部分。一部分是认为托比是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的人，另一部分是认为他不是的人。所以我们要这么做。我们要进行一场老式的辩论，用你们的信件来支持我们的论点。
Our version of a debate for you hardcore debaters out there. We're gonna mess it up. We're not gonna, it's not gonna be like the the debate, but it's gonna be a debate. It's gonna be a debate. It's gonna be a conversation. A mom detective's debate.
对于你们这些铁杆辩论者来说，这是我们的辩论版本。我们要把事情搞砸。我们不会，这不会像那场辩论一样，但它会是一场辩论。它将是一场辩论。这将是一场对话。一场妈妈侦探的辩论。
Thank you. And then after we debate, is Toby the Scranton Strangler, Paul Lieberstein is gonna join us in the studio and tell us what he thinks. And by the way, I say Toby is not the Scranton Strangler. And I say Toby is the Scranton Strangler. And we have not seen each other's arguments. We have not seen each other's evidence.
谢谢。然后在我们辩论完“托比是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔吗”之后，保罗·利伯斯坦将加入我们的工作室，告诉我们他的想法。顺便说一句，我说托比不是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。我说托比是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。而且我们没有看过彼此的论点。我们没有看过彼此的证据。
This is gonna be interesting. Mm-hmm. But before we get into our debate, I thought it might be helpful to give a brief history of the Scranton Strangler. Angela. Mm-hmm. You are doing a summary. This is my favorite day.
这会很有趣。嗯哼。但在我们进入辩论之前，我想提供一份斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的简短历史可能会很有帮助。安吉拉。嗯哼。你在做一个总结。这是我最喜欢的一天。
Jenna's doing like a little shoulder shimmy. She's kind of excited about that. Yes, Jenna, you suggested I do this and I thought, you know what, I'm going to take a stab at it. Oh, I said stab. Not strangle. Okay. You know, I'm doing, I guess my version of a summary. I'm calling it an overview. An overview. I like it. Okay, please proceed. Here is my Scranton Strangler overview.
珍娜做了一个类似耸肩扭动的动作。她对此有点兴奋。是的，珍娜，你建议我这么做的，我想，你知道吗，我要尝试一下。哦，我说尝试（stab）。不是扼杀（strangle）。好吧。你知道的，我在做，我想这是我的总结版本。我称之为概述。一个概述。我喜欢。好的，请继续。这是我的斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔概述。
So the first time the Scranton Strangler is featured is in the sixth season. It was the episode, The Delivery. Now if you remember, everyone is at the hospital waiting for Pam to give birth and Andy arrives with a gift. He has gotten the newspaper from the day Cece was supposed to be born framed. This is a very thoughtful gift. It really is. I don't know if we ever talked about how thoughtful that was of him.
所以斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔第一次登场是在第六季。那是那一集，《分娩》。现在如果你还记得的话，每个人都在医院等待帕姆生孩子，安迪带着一份礼物到了。他把西西出生那天的那份报纸装裱了起来。这是一份非常贴心的礼物。确实如此。我不知道我们是否讨论过他有多贴心。
I know. But then he is annoyed because she wasn't born on the day of the newspaper that he framed. So Andy says, I decided to give Baby Helpert a newspaper from the day she was born. This frame sent me back 55 bones. Yeah. And then Andy shows the camera, the frame newspaper and goes on to say, but she decided to take her sweet time. So now I have to switch it with today's paper.
我知道。但随后他很恼火，因为她不是在他裱起来的那份报纸的出版日出生的。所以安迪说，我决定送给小赫珀特一张她出生当天的报纸。这个镜框花了我 55 块骨头（大洋）。是的。然后安迪向镜头展示了裱好的报纸，接着说，但她决定不慌不忙、慢慢来。所以我现在必须把它换成今天的报纸。
And he holds up the day's paper. Now look, the original newspaper he framed had the headline as, Spring Has Sprung. But that day's newspaper, the headline is Scranton Strangler Strikes Again. Yeah, this is the first time the audience learns about the Scranton Strangler. It would become a running storyline for the remaining seasons of the show. Besides the delivery, it is mentioned in the following episodes, viewing party, happy hour, body language, costume contest, classy Christmas part one, Michael's last Dundee's doomsday, jury duty, the boat, Dwight's Christmas, and moving on.
接着他举起了当天的报纸。现在看，他最初装裱的那份报纸头条是“春天来了”。但当天的报纸，头条是“斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔再次袭击”。是的，这是观众第一次了解到斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。它将成为该剧剩余几季中一个贯穿始终的故事线。除了《分娩》，它还在以下剧集中被提及：观影派对、欢乐时光、肢体语言、化妆比赛、高级圣诞节（上）、迈克尔的最后一个邓迪奖、末日审判、陪审团义务、船、德 Dwight 的圣诞节和继续前行。
And although several other characters referenced the Scranton Strangler throughout the series, it is Toby who seems particularly obsessed with this news headline. And ironically, once the Strangler is apprehended, it is Toby who ends up on the jury that finds the Strangler guilty. After the trial, Toby remains obsessed with the case, and finally he goes to the prison to confront the man
尽管其他几位角色在整个系列中也曾提及斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔，但唯独托比对这个新闻头条表现出特别的痴迷。而且具有讽刺意味的是，一旦扼喉狂魔被捕，托比最终竟然加入了裁定扼喉狂魔有罪的陪审团。审判结束后，托比仍然对这个案件痴迷不已，最后他甚至去监狱与那个
he thinks he wrongly imprisoned. Well Angela that was an excellent overview. Thank you. Guess what I have? I'm gonna take on a little bit of like your thing. I have some digital clutter. Is today Freaky Friday? What is happening in this new year? Are we trading bodies? I don't know. Oh my gosh, I did a summary, you're doing digital clutter. All right, so we once shared that Mindy famously said that The Scranton Strangler was the most pitched storyline in the writer's room. They loved this. I mean, I bet it was fun.
他认为被冤枉入狱的男人对质。好吧，安吉拉，那真是一份极好的概述。谢谢。你猜我有什么？我要借用一点你的东西。我有一些数字杂乱。今天是怪异星期五吗？这个新的一年发生什么了？我们在互换身体吗？我不知道。哦天哪，我做了总结，你在搞数字杂乱。好吧，我们曾经分享过明迪的一句名言，说斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔是编剧室里被推销次数最多的故事线。他们非常喜欢这个。我是说，这肯定很有趣。
And like you said, we were first introduced to The Scranton Strangler in season six, The Delivery. Well, I found three Strangler storylines that were pitched but not produced for season seven. Oh my gosh. Are you ready? Treasure, what? Okay, so I guess over the summer, between season six and seven,
就像你说的，我们是在第六季的《分娩》中首次接触到斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的。好吧，我找到了三个被推销但未能在第七季制作的扼喉狂魔故事线。哦天哪。你准备好了吗？宝藏，什么？好吧，所以我想在第六季和第七季之间的那个夏天，
the writers had this big pitch session. They all had to come back from the break with multiple storyline ideas. And here are the three that involved the Scranton Strangler. Okay. First of all, BJ pitched a storyline that Dwight was gonna try to lay a trap
编剧们开了一场大型的推销会议。他们休假回来时都必须带着多个故事线想法。以下是涉及斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的三个故事线。好的。首先，BJ 推销了一条故事线，说德怀特将尝试为
for the Scranton Strangler. Okay. This was the card, Dwight Lays a Trap for Scranton Strangler. Okay. But there were no other details. Carrie Kemper pitched a storyline similar. You're going to see a similarity between all three of these pitches. Carrie Kemper pitched a storyline that would be part of our Halloween episode.
斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔设下一个陷阱。好的。这就是那张卡片，德怀特为斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔设下陷阱。好的。但没有其他细节。凯丽·肯珀推销了一条相似的故事线。你会发现这三个推销之间有相似之处。凯丽·肯珀推销了一条将成为我们万圣节剧集一部分的故事线。
Okay. Which is that the Scranton Strangler had called the Scranton Times and issued a warning that he was gonna strangle on Halloween night. Oh, this guy's got a lot of attitude. Yeah, this was gonna make everyone really scared to go trick or treating. Okay. So Dwight, here's the common theme, decides to take things into his own hands
好的。那就是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔打电话给《斯克兰顿时报》，发出警告说他将在万圣节之夜进行扼喉。哦，这家伙态度很嚣张啊。是的，这会使每个人都非常害怕去不给糖就捣蛋。好吧。所以德怀特，这里有个共同的主题，决定亲自采取行动，
and he's gonna take Erin to a park and tell her to fall asleep on a park bench and he's gonna like lay in wait. Like use her as bait? Yeah that she's the bait. Oh Erin don't go. But the strangler never strikes. Okay. Was a false alarm all around. No strangling on Halloween after all. Okay. Okay. He's playing games. Yeah. Yeah. This is maybe... Messing with everybody.
他要带艾琳去一个公园，让她在公园长椅上睡着，然后他要在那里埋伏。就像把她当成诱饵？对，她就是诱饵。哦，艾琳，别去。但扼喉狂魔从未出现。好吧。虚惊一场。万圣节终究没有发生扼喉事件。好吧。好吧。他在玩游戏。对。对。这或许是……在捉弄所有人。
Maybe some insight into the strangler. I'm just adding to the card. Oh, that's how our session works, right? Yeah. Then Robert Padnick pitched this story. It was a card that said extra security because of Scranton Strangler. And in this pitch, as the building manager, Dwight was going to really buckle down to protect everyone
或许对扼喉狂魔有一些深入了解。我只是在往卡片上补充。哦，我们的会议就是这么运作的，对吧？是的。然后罗伯特·帕德尼克推销了这个故事。卡片上写着：因斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔而加强安保。在这场推销中，作为大楼管理员，德怀特将全力以赴保护每个人
from the Strangler. He was going to put up barbed wire and metal detectors. He was going to get a Doberman. The problem is that this scary dog that was supposed to protect everyone ends up being just like a complete love bug. And then everybody just falls in love with this dog. And then I don't know where that was going to go if we were just going to have a dog. But these were the three pitches that I was able to dig out of my producer's digital clutter.
免受扼喉狂魔的侵害。他要架设铁丝网和金属探测器。他要弄来一只杜宾犬。问题是，这只本该保护大家的吓人狗狗，最后却完全成了一只小可爱。然后每个人都爱上了这只狗狗。然后我不知道这会走向何方，如果我们只是养了一只狗的话。但这就是我从我的制作人的数字杂乱中挖掘出来的三个推销。
You know, here's the one flaw with that Robert Padnick card, which is that if Dwight put up metal detectors, he'd never be able to come into the office with all of his stuff. This is so true. I'm sure he had an alternate entrance for himself. That's really fun. We're gonna have to ask Paul about all of that when he joins the show.
你知道，罗伯特·帕德尼克那张卡片有一个瑕疵，那就是如果德怀特安装了金属探测器，他自己就永远无法带着他所有的东西进入办公室了。这太对了。我确信他为自己准备了一个备用入口。这真的很有趣。等保罗加入节目时，我们得向他打听所有这些事。
I have so many questions for Paul. I know. All right, well, are we ready for our opening statements? Angela, would you like to go first? Yes, I just want to put this out there. I have never debated anything and I tried to follow the little outline you sent me, Jenna. So, I'm not sure this qualifies as an opening statement, but here it is. Are you ready? Hello. That's a good start. Welcome, Cassie, Sam, Jenna, and all of you listening out there in the world. Welcome to the first ever Office Ladies Debate. I, Angela Kinsey, am taking the position that Toby Flinderson is
我对保罗有好多问题要问。我知道。好吧，那么，我们准备好发表开场陈述了吗？安吉拉，你想先来吗？是的，我只想先说明这一点。我从来没有辩论过任何事情，我试着遵循你发给我的那个小提纲，珍娜。所以，我不确定这是否符合开场陈述的标准，但就是这样。你准备好了吗？你好。这是个不错的开始。欢迎，卡西、萨姆、珍娜，以及所有在世界各地聆听的你们。欢迎来到史上第一场办公室辣妈辩论赛。我，安吉拉·金斯利，持有的立场是托比·弗林德森
indeed the Scranton Strangler. Today, I will prove the true nature of Toby Flinderson and the crimes he most certainly committed. Now, you might say, shy, mild-natured Toby? The sometimes helpful HR rep who sat quietly in the corner of the annex? Could he really be capable of this type of violent crime? But ladies and gentlemen, I really don't have to say much. Toby will tell you in his own words that he in fact has a very sinister nature. Furthermore, I will provide hard evidence that
确实是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。今天，我要证明托比·弗林德森的真实本质以及他毫无疑问犯下的罪行。现在，你可能会说，害羞、温和的托比？那个静静地坐在附楼角落里、有时乐于助人的 HR 代表？他真的有能力犯下这种暴力罪行吗？但女士们先生们，我其实不需要多说什么。托比会用他自己的话告诉你，他事实上有着非常阴暗的本质。此外，我将提供确凿的证据，
reveals that Toby is the Scranton Strangler. Wow. Oh, watch yourself, counselor. May I approach the bench? Yes. Okay. All right, that was great. I will start by saying I've also never done this. I was not in debate in school.
揭示托比就是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。哇哦。哦，小心点，辩护律师。我可以走近陪审席吗？可以。好的。好吧，太棒了。我先说，我也从来没做过这个。我在学校里没参加过辩论赛。
Me either. I think I did one debate in one history class once in high school. My closest thing to debate is watching, what was that Tom Cruise movie? You Can't Handle the Truths. Oh, a few good men. A few good men.
我也是。我想我在高中时只在一堂历史课上辩论过一次。我离辩论最近的经历是看，那是汤姆·克鲁斯的哪部电影来着？《义海雄风》（你承受不了真相）。哦，《好人寥寥》。《好人寥寥》。
I rewatched that this past year. Well, that's the closest I've come to debate. Really good. Yeah. All right, here's my opening statement. Okay. Sam, Cassie, esteemed listeners, Angela. Thank you.
我去年又看了一遍。好吧，这是我离辩论最近的一次了。非常不错。是的。好吧，这是我的开场陈述。好的。萨姆、卡西、尊敬的听众们、安吉拉。谢谢。
It is my position that Toby is not the Scranton Strangler. I will present evidence or rather point out the lack of evidence that shows Toby is not a criminal. And while I personally believe that George Howard Scubb is the real Scranton Strangler, I will also offer alternate suspects, all of whom are more likely than Toby Flenderson, to have committed these crimes.
我的立场是托比不是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。我将展示证据，或者更准确地说，指出缺乏证据来证明托比不是罪犯。虽然我个人认为乔治·霍华德·斯库布才是真正的斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔，但我也会提供其他嫌疑人，他们所有人都比托比·弗林德森更有可能犯下这些罪行。
I believe that Toby believes he convicted the wrong man. I believe he might start a podcast to try to find the real killer. But this is not out of guilt for being the true Scranton Strangler, but rather because Toby's life lacks excitement. And the Scranton Strangler trial was perhaps the happiest we've ever seen Toby. His face lights up when given the chance to talk about it. I believe he's grasping at this one moment of excitement.
我相信托比坚信自己把错误的人定罪了。我相信他可能会发起一个播客来试图找到真正的凶手。但这并不是出于身为真正的斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的内疚，而是因为托比的生活缺乏刺激。斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的审判或许是我们见过的托比最开心的时候。当有机会谈论它时，他的脸都亮了起来。我相信他是在抓住这唯一的一个刺激时刻。
I would like to conclude my opening statement with these words from Celia S. in Plymouth, Minnesota. George Howard Scubb is the Scranton Strangler, and Toby is just a weird man who's obsessed with murder mysteries, probably because his own life is actually so boring. I'm not a Toby hater or a Toby defender. I to be. Toby is Toby. Thank you. Well, I mean, I know we're on opposite sides, but I thought that was really well done. I mean, I thought yours was great too.
我想用明尼苏达州普利茅斯的西莉亚·S的这些话来结束我的开场陈述。乔治·霍华德·斯库布是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔，而托比只是一个痴迷于谋杀悬疑小说的怪人，这大概是因为他自己的生活实在太无聊了。我不是托比黑，也不是托比粉。我就是托比。托比就是托比。谢谢。好吧，我的意思是，我知道我们站在对立面，但我认为这真的做得很好。我是说，我觉得你的也很棒。
Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will each give our constructive speeches. All right on our positions. Okay. All right we're back. So when I sent us the little debate structure, it said opening statements and then we each give a constructive speech and then we have rebuttal time. I don't totally know how that works, but I'm getting out a pen and paper. Oh, you're going to write notes to rebut for my rebuttal.
好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？当我们回来时，我们将各自发表建设性的演讲。好的，关于我们的立场。好的。好吧，我们回来了。所以当我把那个小辩论结构发给我们时，上面写着开场陈述，然后我们每人做一个建设性的演讲，然后我们有反驳时间。我完全不知道那是怎么运作的，但我正在拿出纸和笔。哦，你要写笔记来为我的反驳做准备。
Okay. Because I think my rebuttal is in real time, right? I thought rebuttals- Did you write a rebuttal? I thought they came at the end. They come at the end. I did speech and debate in high school. Oh, Kathy! Oh my gosh, please get in here. So you have to listen to each other's arguments
好吧。因为我觉得我的反驳是实时的，对吧？我以为反驳——你写了反驳吗？我以为它们是在最后才出现的。它们在最后。我在高中时参加过演讲和辩论。哦，凯西！哦天哪，请进。所以你们必须听取彼此的论点，
and you can be writing while they're making the arguments, but you wanna have a rebuttal against whatever they say and make your argument stronger. At the end? Yeah, so it'll be argument, argument, rebuttal, rebuttal. In conclusion. Yeah, all right.
而且你们可以在对方阐述论点时做笔记，但你们希望针对他们所说的任何内容进行反驳，并使你们的论点更有力。在最后？是的，所以将是论点、论点、反驳、反驳。最后总结。是的，好吧。
So now, while Angela's talking, I'm just writing, but am I allowed to do things like, mm? Oh! Am I allowed to do stuff like that or no? No, but for the sake of the podcast, I think you can. Okay, just wanna know what rules. Oh. Am I allowed to do stuff like that or no? No. Probably not. But for the sake of the podcast, I think you can. Okay. Okay.
所以现在，当安吉拉说话时，我只是在写字，但我被允许做诸如“嗯？”之类的事情吗？哦！我被允许做那种事情还是不行？不，但为了播客的效果，我想你可以。好的，只是想知道规则是什么。哦。我被允许做那种事情还是不行？不。大概不行。但为了播客的效果，我想你可以。好的。好的。
Just want to know what rules. I did not write an in conclusion, so I'll have to wing that one. Well, I'm winging it because I want to hear what Paul has to say. Oh, our in conclusions come after Paul. After Paul. All right. Okay. Okay.
只是想知道规则是什么。我没有写最后总结，所以我得临场发挥了。好吧，我在临场发挥，因为我想听听保罗要说些什么。哦，我们的最后总结在保罗之后。保罗之后。好吧。好的。好的。
Here we go. Angela, you're up. Okay. Here I go. I feel like I'm in front of like a high school classroom. I have all of those feelings of like, oh no. Okay, I am ready to present my case that Toby is the Scranton Strangler. First of all, let's ask the question, does Toby fit the profile of a serial killer? The evidence says he does.
我们开始吧。安吉拉，轮到你了。好的。轮到我了。我觉得自己就像站在一个高中文科教室前面。我所有的那种“哦不”的感觉都涌上心头。好吧，我已经准备好陈述我的案子了，证明托比就是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。首先，让我们问一个问题，托比符合连环杀手的特征吗？证据表明他符合。
According to the U.S. Department of Justice, 85% of serial killers are male and 82% are white. Check, check, Toby. According to the FBI, serial murders often seem normal, have families or a steady job. Hmm, a human resources rep at a paper company. Again, check Toby. Studies have found that a significant percentage of serial killers come from broken homes.
根据美国司法部的数据，85% 的连环杀手是男性，82% 是白人。符合，符合，托比。根据 FBI 的说法，连环杀手通常看起来很正常，有家庭或稳定的工作。嗯，一家纸业公司的HR代表。再次，符合，托比。研究发现，相当大比例的连环杀手来自破裂的家庭。
As a result of their trauma, they may suppress their emotional response and may have difficulty empathizing with others. They often suffer from a variety of personality disorders, psychopathy, and antisocial personality. Let's see if Toby checks that box off. Hmm. In the episode, The Deposition, we learned that Toby's parents divorced when he was a child.
由于他们的创伤，他们可能会压抑自己的情感反应，并且可能难以对他人产生同理心。他们经常患有各种人格障碍、精神病态和反社会人格。让我们看看托比是否符合这一条。嗯。在《听证会》那一集中，我们得知托比的父母在他还是个孩子时就离婚了。
Both of them wanted custody, and both asked him to testify against the other in court. He was unsure what to do because he loved both of his parents wanted custody and both asked him to testify against the other in court. He was unsure what to do because he loved both of his parents and didn't want them to get divorced in the first place. That was certainly traumatic for Toby. And we learn Toby himself goes through a bitter divorce. Check Toby.
他们两个都想要抚养权，并且都要求他在法庭上作证指控对方。他不知道该怎么办，因为他爱他们两个，而且父母双方都想要抚养权，并且都要求他在法庭上作证指控对方。他不知道该怎么办，因为他爱他的父母双方，而且一开始就不希望他们离婚。这对托比来说无疑是痛苦的。我们得知托比自己也经历了一场痛苦的离婚。符合，托比。
Next up, studies also find that serial killers find comfort in their fantasies and dreams that take them into a realm that only they can control. Hmm, let's see, does Toby fit that profile? His wife left him, he feels alone, he loved Pam, but she didn't love him back, he has a boss that hates him and bullies him, he can't control his real life, so he creates a fantasy life through a character he made up, Chad Flenderson. That is where he can be in control.
接下来，研究还发现，连环杀手在他们的幻想和梦境中寻求慰藉，这些幻想和梦境将他们带入一个只有他们自己能掌控的领域。嗯，让我们看看，托比符合这个特征吗？他的妻子离开了他，他感到孤独，他爱帕姆，但帕姆不爱他，他有一个恨他、欺负他的老板，他无法掌控自己的现实生活，所以他通过自己虚构的一个角色——查德·弗林德森——创造了一个幻想生活。那是他可以掌控一切的地方。
In fact, one of Toby's mystery novels is titled, A Murder for Framing. Toby is sharing his knowledge of how to frame someone for murder. It's literally the title of his book. In the episode Christmas Wishes, Toby, through his cover of being this mystery writer, reveals how you could put someone else's fingerprints on a crime scene. It happens when Dwight gets quilled by the porcupine. Andy says to Jim, this has your fingerprints all over it. Jim turns to Andy and says, Andy, you've got to be kidding me.
事实上，托比的一部悬疑小说题为《嫁祸谋杀》。托比正在分享他关于如何将谋杀罪嫁祸于人的知识。这简直就是他书的名字。在《圣诞愿望》一书中，托比通过他身为悬疑小说作家的掩护，透露了你如何将别人的指纹留在犯罪现场。这发生在德怀特被豪猪扎了刺的时候。安迪对吉姆说，这上面全都是你的指纹。吉姆转向安迪说，安迪，你一定是在开玩笑。
And then Toby pipes up and says, fingerprints can be planted, you know, with like a severed hand or what is happening here? Toby is describing how to frame someone in front of everyone. Toby goes on to further say Chad as a character is a very complex individual and he deals with a lot of personal issues. So Toby checks all the boxes here folks.
然后托比插话道，指纹是可以伪造的，你知道的，可以用像断手之类的方法，或者这里发生什么了？托比在所有人面前描述了如何陷害一个人。托比接着进一步说，查德作为一个角色是一个非常复杂的个体，他要处理很多个人问题。所以各位，托比符合这里所有的条件。
And ladies and gentlemen, Sam, Cassie and Jenna, now that we have established that Toby fits the profile of a violent criminal, let's look at some hard evidence that further proves Toby is the Scranton Strangler. Are you ready? Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. You're not doing poorly so far. You've written three notes.
女士们先生们，萨姆、卡西和珍娜，既然我们已经确定托比符合暴力罪犯的特征，让我们来看看一些进一步证明托比是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的确凿证据。你们准备好了吗？嗯哼。嗯哼。你目前表现得还不错。你写了三张便条。
I can't see what they say. I'm not going to look at her papers, okay? Here we go on to my next part. It all started with rejection. Becca N. from Berwyn, Illinois writes in to say, Toby is absolutely the Scranton Strangler. Let me lay out the evidence. Becca, you do a fantastic job by the way, sidebar. Becca says Toby turned his back on his initial passions, the seminary, to get into a relationship with a woman. And it's implied that she ended up leaving him. And now he's stuck in a dead-end job
我看不清上面写的是什么。我不会看她的纸的，好吧？我们继续进入我的下一部分。这一切都始于拒绝。来自伊利诺伊州伯温的贝卡·N.来信说，托比绝对是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。让我列举证据。顺便说一句，贝卡，你做得很棒，插播一句。贝卡说，托比背弃了他最初的热情——神学院，去和一个女人谈恋爱。暗示最后是她抛弃了他。现在他被困在了一份死胡同的工作中，
where he doesn't get to use his brain. He's very undervalued, not just by Michael, but everyone else. He's constantly bullied and generally mocked and ridiculed. And of course, he was deeply upset by the thought of the police going into his desk because he's hiding something. The killing starts being mentioned after Pam got married. He had an obsession with Pam and is disappointed at losing her to Jim and that is manifested into a murderous rage. Pam is having another man's baby and someone dies the same day? Then there's the part where the baby is christened. Toby goes to the church and he can't go in. Later he asks God, why are you always so mean to me? Someone else agrees. Sam
在那里他无法发挥自己的大脑。他被严重低估了，不仅被迈克尔低估，也被其他人低估。他经常被欺负，通常受到嘲笑和奚落。当然，一想到警察要搜查他的办公桌，他就深感不安，因为他在隐藏什么。在帕姆结婚后，杀戮开始被提及。他对帕姆有一种执念，对失去帕姆给吉姆感到失望，这演变成了一种杀戮的怒火。帕姆怀上了另一个男人的孩子，而同一天有人死了？然后还有孩子受洗的那一部分。托比去了教堂，但他进不去。后来他问上帝，你为什么总是对我这么刻薄？另一个人表示赞同。萨姆
Kay from Los Angeles. In our Office Ladies episode, Breakdown, the Christening, Sam said, you know, who wouldn't want to enter a church because they have a problem with God? And then Sam answers himself, a strangler. Okay, I feel like that's a little pandering to the jury, using our jury's own words. Bringing. Wait, is this allowed? Is this like, are you, is this approach the bench moment? No, this is absolutely not allowed.
凯来自洛杉矶。在我们的办公室辣妈剧集《崩溃，洗礼》中，萨姆说，你知道的，谁会因为对上帝有意见而不想进教堂呢？然后萨姆自问自答道，扼喉狂魔。好吧，我觉得这有点迎合陪审团，用了我们陪审团自己的原话。带来。等等，这允许吗？这就像是，你是，这是一个走近陪审席的时刻吗？不，这绝对不允许。
And if Sam is the judge, he needs to like leave. I need to recuse myself at this point. Yes. Sam clearly needs to recuse. Cassie is now our only judge. Okay, sorry Sam. You're part of the argument, sorry. All right.
如果萨姆是法官，他需要离开。我此时需要回避。是的。萨姆显然需要回避。卡西现在是我们唯一的法官了。好吧，对不起，萨姆。你是辩论的一部分，抱歉。好吧。
Now let's point out some of Toby's strange behavior that is prone to being irrational, aggressive, suspicious, and sinister. That is further evidence that he is the Scranton Strangler. Number one, irrational behavior. Like out of nowhere saying he is going to Costa Rica. Fan theory from Angela Kay, also on this podcast, also in the christening episode quoted as saying, if you were the Scranton Strangler, you would need to have a place to go and hide.
现在让我们指出托比一些倾向于不理性、好斗、可疑和阴险的奇怪行为。这是他是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的进一步证据。第一点，不理性的行为。比如毫无征兆地突然说他要去哥斯达黎加。安吉拉·凯的粉丝理论，同样在这个播客中，也在洗礼那一集中被引用，她说道，如果你是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔，你需要有一个地方去躲藏。
He clearly has set up a second residence or even a different identity in Costa Rica. Liv from Vancouver writes in with this excellent point, what are your thoughts on the fact that Toby always keeps his passport with him mentioned when he's having a conversation with Mrs. California? My theory is that he needs it in case he ever has to flee the country. Who said that? Liv. Liv. From Vancouver. Okay. I have some words for Liv later. Oh, okay. Well, Liv, get ready. Next up are things that Toby
他显然在哥斯达黎加建立了一个第二个住所甚至是一个不同的身份。来自温哥华的丽芙写信提出了这个极好的观点，对于托比总是随身携带护照这一事实，你们有什么看法？当他和卡利福尼亚太太交谈时提到了这一点。我的理论是，他需要护照以防他不得不逃离这个国家。谁说的？丽芙。来自温哥华。好吧。我一会儿要跟丽芙说几句话。哦，好吧。好吧，丽芙，准备好。接下来是托比隐藏的事情。
hides. He's actually quite athletic. Proof of this is in Night Out. We also had a fan theory that we shared on this very own podcast from Carolyn G. She said, since Toby jumps the fence with such apparent ease, it shows that he's someone who might be able to escape the police. Is this evidence that Toby is the Scranton Strangler? Jenna, Jenna F from Los Angeles said, she asked Paul about this and Paul's response was, sounds smart.
他其实相当运动。这方面的证据在《夜出》中。我们在本期播客中也分享过来自卡罗琳·G 的粉丝理论。她说，既然托比能如此轻盈自如地跳过栅栏，这说明他可能是一个能够逃脱警察追捕的人。这是托比是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的证据吗？来自洛杉矶的珍娜·F 说，她就此事问过保罗，保罗的回答是，听起来很聪明。
Okay, all right. Judge, judge, are we allowed to use Paul in here? What is happening? You're playing fast and loose with this. Why can't I quote? Like a cop who's two days from retirement. Why can't I quote the person who plays the character who also was a writer?
好吧，好吧。法官，法官，我们可以在这里提到保罗吗？这到底是怎么回事？你在这个问题上太随心所欲了。为什么我不能引用？就像一个离退休还有两天的警察一样。为什么我不能引用那个扮演角色同时也是编剧的人的话呢？
Oh boy. All right. Next up. Around the thin ice. You have been recused. This whole thing's about to go out the window. Oh gosh. It's going to be blown out the window. Next up, Toby's aggressive behavior. Like this moment when Clark interrupts Toby and Jim talking. Let's hear it. Hey Toby, I wanted to ask you a question. Oh sure. It's a little personal. Let's do it. Let's get personal.
哦天哪。接下来。如履薄冰。你已经被要求回避了。整件事都要泡汤了。哦天哪。要被大风吹走了。接下来，托比的好斗行为。比如克拉克打断托比和吉姆谈话的这一刻。我们来听听。嘿，托比，我想问你个问题。哦，当然。有点私事。说吧。我们谈点私事。
I wanted to talk to you about your divorce. Whoa. Sorry. I didn't know what I meant. What I meant actually was it's okay. I can handle it. You guys obviously went through some tough times. Okay. I was wondering if you ever did any couples counseling? Oh, sure, lots of times, yeah.
我想跟你聊聊你的离婚。哇。抱歉。我不是那个意思。我的意思是其实没关系。我能应付。你们俩显然经历了一些艰难时期。好吧。我想知道你是否做过婚姻咨询？哦，当然，很多次，是的。
Wait, you and Pam are in couples counseling, are you? Oh, God. No, no, no, no, we're just starting couples counseling. Which doesn't sound any better. Even you guys. Kelly called it. 2013. Hey, hey, hey, no, no. Get out of here. Clark, get out of here. My mistake. Yes, it is your mistake.
等等，你和帕姆在做婚姻咨询，是吗？哦，天哪。不，不，不，不，我们才刚开始做婚姻咨询。这听起来并没有好到哪里去。你们也是。凯莉说中了。2013 年。嘿，嘿，嘿，不，不。滚开。克拉克，滚开。我的错。是的，这就是你的错。
He's lingering. He's so annoying. I'm gonna kill him. I'm going to kill him. That's what Toby said when Clark interrupts him. I'm going to kill him. For more suspicious behavior we have in Viewing Party everyone is gathered around Toby's desk watching the police pursuit of the Scranton Strangler. Fans have pointed out a few important things. Number one, where is Toby? Everyone else at Dunder Mifflin is there. We have a fan theory from Angela Kay in Los Angeles.
他还在磨蹭。太烦人了。我要杀了他。我要杀了他。克拉克打断他时，托比是这么说的。为了了解更多可疑行为，我们在《观影派对》中看到大家聚在托比的办公桌周围观看对斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的警方追捕。粉丝们指出了几个重要的事情。第一，托比在哪里？邓德米夫林的其他人都在那儿。我们有来自洛杉矶的安吉拉·凯的粉丝理论。
Might the documentary film crew have suspected it was Toby all along? And is this why they purposely included this footage in the documentary film? They wanted to highlight the fact that Toby was not at work the day the Strangler was fleeing, and there's also something else.
纪录片摄制组会不会一直怀疑是托比？这是否就是他们故意在纪录片中加入这段录像的原因？他们想强调这样一个事实：扼喉狂魔逃跑的那天托比不在工作岗位上，而且还有别的事情。
A letter from Taylor C. in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. The staff is seated at Toby's desk when his phone rings on the day that the police are pursuing the falsely accused Strangler. In addition to attempting to contact him, the caller must have known Toby's extension directly, because Aaron was not at reception forwarding the calls. Given he has few acquaintances and hardly ever gets direct calls,
一封来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的泰勒·C的信。当警方正在追捕被诬陷的扼喉狂魔的那天，员工们正坐在托比的办公桌前，这时他的电话响了。除了试图联系他之外，来电者一定知道托比的直接分机号，因为艾琳当时不在前台转接电话。鉴于他没什么熟人，也几乎从不接直接打来的电话，
this is extremely suspicious and suggests that Toby might be framing George Howard's scub. Doug Wye from Spokane, Washington. Notice that the car the strangler used during the chase was previously seen in the background shots of the parking lot of the office. Did Toby provide George with the car? Further part of how to frame a murderer. And then there's Toby's obsession with being on the jury for the case. Jenna, you mentioned this. He seemed delighted. He seemed so happy. Well, many people wrote in and noted that Toby is happy to be on the jury because he knows he got away
这极其可疑，并暗示托比可能在陷害乔治·霍华德·斯库布。来自华盛顿州斯波坎的道格·怀伊。请注意，扼喉狂魔在追捕过程中使用的汽车以前曾出现在办公室停车场背景镜头中。是托比给乔治提供了这辆车吗？这是如何陷害一个杀人犯的进一步部分。还有就是托比对加入该案陪审团的痴迷。珍娜，你提到过这个。他看起来很高兴。他看起来太开心了。嗯，许多人写信指出，托比很高兴能加入陪审团，因为他知道自己逃脱了惩罚，
with it. Someone else is going to pay for his crime and he's going to help make sure of it. He is going to convict an innocent person to cover his tracks as the Scranton Strangler, as he planned all along by framing George. And several people wrote in and noted, including Jennifer G from Tampa, Florida, saying that they believe that when Toby went to see George in prison, he was going to say to him, I know you're innocent because I did it.
有人将为他的罪行买单，而他将确保这一点。他要将一个无辜的人定罪，以掩盖他作为斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的行踪，正如他通过陷害乔治一直计划的那样。几个人写信指出，包括来自佛罗里达州坦帕市的珍妮弗·G，他们认为当托比去监狱看望乔治时，他是去对他说，我知道你是无辜的，因为是我干的。
He is sinister, he is evil. He has a dark nature. He was proud of this crime. He was taunting him and George strangled him as a response. But lastly, to really show Toby's true sinister nature, let's just hear it from Toby himself. We should really have the offices air quality tested. We have radon from Toby himself. We should really have the office's air quality tested. We have radon coming from below. We have asbestos in the ceilings. These are silent killers. You are the silent killer.
他很阴险，他很邪恶。他有着黑暗的本质。他为这起罪行感到骄傲。他在挑衅乔治，而乔治作为回应勒死了他。但最后，为了真正展现托比阴暗的本性，让我们听听托比自己的话。我们真的应该给办公室做个空气质量检测。我们有氡气来自托比本人。我们真的应该检测办公室的空气质量。我们有氡气从下面冒上来。天花板上有石棉。这些都是无声杀手。你才是无声杀手。
Go back to the annex. You'll see. You'll see. You'll see who the silent killer is, Michael. This is a person who is bitter, unhappy, jealous, rejected, a loner who had the motive to kill, the ability to kill, and the arrogance to brag about it in front of a camera crew. They knew he did it. Toby tells us he did it.
回到你的附楼去。你会看到的。你会看到的。你会看到谁才是无声杀手，迈克尔。这是一个痛苦、不快乐、嫉妒、被拒绝、孤僻的人，他有杀人的动机、杀人的能力，还有在镜头前大肆炫耀的傲慢。他们知道是他干的。托比亲口告诉我们是他干的。
Believe him. Toby Flinderson is the Scranton Strangler. Wow. Wow. Wow. Okay. That's as far as I got, guys. I'm going to say I am a little surprised to hear that you were not in debate because I thought that was excellent. Oh, thank you.
相信他。托比·弗林德森就是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。哇哦。哇哦。哇哦。好吧。各位，我只讲到这里。我要说的是，听到你没有参加过辩论，我感到有点惊讶，因为我认为那太棒了。哦，谢谢。
Yes. Cassie, are debates usually this friendly? No, but I love how friendly this one is. We will continue. Okay. Well, I guess it's my turn. Well, let me just tell you, the jury is feisty in there. Oh. The judge has a lot of comments. We lost a judge. We lost a judge, but he's still very chatty. So anyway, I wish you luck. Thank you. Thank you so much. Ladies and gentlemen, I'm gonna present three very strong reasons why Toby is not the Scranton Strangler.
是的。卡西，辩论通常都这么友好吗？不，但我喜欢这一场有多友好。我们将继续。好吧。嗯，我想轮到我了。好吧，我只想告诉你们，里面的陪审团很不服输呢。哦。法官有很多评论。我们少了一位法官，但他还是很健谈。总之，祝你好运。谢谢。非常感谢。女士们先生们，我要提出三个非常有力的理由，证明托比不是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔。
Starting with a lack of direct evidence. There is simply no concrete evidence linking Toby to these murders. Now I will admit, there's not a lot of evidence or details of the strangler's crimes, but we do know a few things. Number one, we know that there was a car chase that led to the arrest of George Howard Scub, and I would ask this question,
首先是没有直接证据。根本没有确凿的证据将托比与这些谋杀案联系起来。现在我承认，关于扼喉狂魔罪行的证据或细节并不多，但我们确实知道一些事情。第一，我们知道有一场汽车追逐导致了乔治·霍华德·斯库布的被捕，我会问这样一个问题，
why did George Howard Scubb run from police and barricade himself inside of an apartment complex if he was not guilty of this crime? Some people have suggested that Toby was driving the car since he is not in the scene where everyone is watching the chase. Maybe Toby ran into the apartment complex and then escaped,
如果乔治·霍华德·斯库布没有犯下这起罪行，他为什么要躲避警察并在一个公寓大楼里 barricade（设路障死守）自己？有些人认为托比当时开着这辆车，因为大家都在看追捕的那一幕中没有他。也许托比跑进了公寓大楼然后逃跑了，
leaving George Howard Scubb to take the fall. But here's the thing. Where did Toby get this Mercury Cougar? This is not Toby's car. Angela, you yourself pointed out that in season one, Toby has a photo of a Jeep at his desk. In season two- You're doing what I did.
留下乔治·霍华德·斯库布当替罪羊。但问题是。托比是从哪里弄来这辆水星美洲狮的？这不是托比的车。安吉拉，你自己也指出，在第一季中，托比的桌子上有一张吉普车的照片。在第二季——你在做我做过的事。
You're quoting from our own podcast. Judge. Slight objection, but I'll allow it. Thank you. Thank you. In season two episode, take your daughter to work day, Toby drives a silver Saab. And then in season eight, the garden party, he's driving a Subaru Impreza. None of the Dunder Mifflin staff are ever seen driving this mercury cougar that is
你在引用我们自己的播客。法官大人。轻微反对，但我批准。谢谢。谢谢。在第二季第“带女儿上班日”那一集里，托比开着一辆银色的萨博。然后在第八季《花园派对》中，他开着一辆斯巴鲁翼豹。邓德米夫林的员工中没有人被看到开过这辆处于扼喉狂魔案核心的水星美洲狮。
at the center of the Strangler case. This would mean that Toby, our underpaid HR rep, somehow has two cars? A Strangler car and another car? I doubt that is the case. In Dwight's Christmas, Toby is recounting his theories about the Scranton Strangler, Tonelli. He mentions that they found fingerprints, presumably linked to George Howard Scubb.
这意味着托比，我们这位薪水过低的 HR 代表，不知怎么的拥有两辆车？一辆扼喉狂魔的车和另一辆车？我对此表示怀疑。在德怀特的圣诞节那一集中，托比正在讲述他对斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔托内利的理论。他提到他们找到了指纹，据推测这些指纹与乔治·霍华德·斯库布有关。
How did George Howard Scubb's fingerprints get on coins found at one of the crime scenes if he's not the Scranton Strangler? Hmm? Oh! Hmm-hmm. Okay. the crime scenes if he's not the Scranton Strangler. You might notice that none of Toby's fingerprints were found at any of the crime scenes and if they were we would know about it because he has traveled abroad and it is customary to provide fingerprints in order to obtain a passport. So clearly Toby's
如果乔治·霍华德·斯库布不是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔，他的指纹是怎么出现在犯罪现场找到的硬币上的呢？嗯？哦！嗯哼。好的。犯罪现场，如果他不是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔的话？你可能会注意到，在任何犯罪现场都没有发现托比的指纹，如果有的话，我们会知道的，因为他曾出国旅行，而为了获得护照，提供指纹是习俗。所以显然托比的
fingerprints have been cleared. And while Toby might doubt the validity of these fingerprints as being accurate, there have been many cases of police being able to lift fingerprints from money and get convictions, just like they did in this case, because criminals often think to wear gloves while committing a crime, but not when handling their own money.
指纹已经被排除了。虽然托比可能会怀疑这些指纹是否准确，但有许多案例表明警方能够从钱币上提取指纹并定罪，就像他们在这个案子中所做的那样，因为罪犯在犯罪时通常会记得戴手套，但在处理自己的钱时却不会。
And finally, I would say that the fact that George Howard Scubb tries to strangle Toby during his visit to the prison is pretty clear evidence that George Howard Scubb is the strangler. But now I'd like to go to character consistency. Per the FBI, psychopaths who commit serial murder do not value human life and are extremely callous in their interactions with their victims.
最后，我要说的是，乔治·霍华德·斯库布在监狱探视期间试图勒死托比这一事实，是乔治·霍华德·斯库布就是扼喉狂魔的相当明显的证据。但现在我想谈谈角色的连贯性。根据联邦调查局的说法，犯下连环谋杀案的精神病态者不珍视生命，在与受害者的交往中极其冷酷。
One strategy to assess whether a person is a psychopath is to look at four dimensions, deviance, distress, dysfunction, and danger, collectively known as the four D's. Toby's character is largely depicted as mild-mannered and empathetic, making it difficult to believe that he is a serial killer. Ellen Kay from Robinson, Illinois said, I don't think serial killers participate in Movember. I would also like to quote Jenna F. from Los Angeles, who said, why would Toby be so worried about us all dying of radon poisoning if he was the Scranton Strangler? Wouldn't he want us all to slowly suffocate?
评估一个人是否是精神病态者的一种策略是查看四个维度：偏差（deviance）、痛苦（distress）、功能失调（dysfunction）和危险（danger），统称为“四个D”。托比的角色在很大程度上被描绘成温和且富有同情心，这让人很难相信他是一个连环杀手。来自伊利诺伊州鲁滨逊的埃伦·K 说，我不认为连环杀手会参加“莫韦伯”（Movember胡须月）。我还想引用洛杉矶的珍娜·F 的话说，如果托比是斯克兰顿扼喉狂魔，他为什么会这么担心我们所有人都死于氡气中毒？难道他不想让我们所有人都慢慢窒息吗？
That sounds like the perfect crime. Finally, I'd like to point to some other suspects. Sure, you don't believe it's George Howard Scubb? How about Creed Bratton? Madison S. from Covington, Kentucky said everyone thinks it's Toby who could be the Scranton Strangler. Why does no one suspect Creed?
这听起来像是一场完美的犯罪。最后，我想指出其他一些嫌疑人。当然，你不相信那是乔治·霍华德·斯库布？克里德·布拉顿怎么样？来自肯塔基州卡温顿的麦迪逊·S说，每个人都觉得可能是托比，他才是斯克兰顿扼杀狂。为什么没有人怀疑克里德？
He came into the office during the murder mystery episode and freaked out when Michael, quote, blamed him for murder, and he also had blood on himself in the Halloween episode. Seems pretty viable that it could be Creed. Amber C. from Oregon said, It is definitely Creed. Not to mention Creed's impromptu talking head when the police were searching for weed and he says,
他在谋杀悬疑剧集里来到办公室，当迈克尔“指责”他谋杀时，他吓坏了，而且他在万圣节剧集里身上也有血。克里德是凶手的可能性似乎相当高。来自俄勒冈州的安贝尔·C说：绝对是克里德。更不用说当警察搜查大麻时，克里德即兴对着镜头说：
Just keep talking until the cops leave. Also, why was Creed in the middle of nowhere on the side of the road hitchhiking to work during work bus? Not to mention the wanted posters in the finale. And Jessica J. from Sweden said, "'Creed has stolen an identity "'and he's up to so many funky businesses. "'Why wouldn't he be the Strangler too?' "'And in viewing party, Jim has a line
只要一直说话，直到警察离开。还有，为什么在工作大巴那集里，克里德会在荒郊野岭的路边搭便车去上班？更不用说大结局里的通缉令了。来自瑞典的杰西卡·J说：“克里德偷了一个身份，他干了好多见不得人的勾当。他为什么不能也是扼杀狂呢？”而在观影派对那一集里，吉姆有一句台词：
"'when they're watching the car trace "'that says, huh, I guess the Scranton Grant and Strangler isn't who I thought he was. Pam says, why? And Jim says, because the person I thought it was just showed up to work. And then we see Creed walking in. But fine, you don't think it's Creed? How about Gabe? Alexis L. from Stanton Island, New York said,
当他们在看汽车追踪时说：“呃，我猜斯克兰顿扼杀狂不是我想的那个人。”帕姆说：“为什么？”吉姆说：“因为我以为的那个人刚刚来上班了。”然后我们看到克里德走了进来。不过好吧，你觉得不是克里德？加布怎么样？来自纽约史泰登岛的莱克西·L说：
I think it's far more likely Gabe is the strangler. It's well established that he enjoys violence and horror. He travels between Scranton and Florida, which makes it easy to elude police. And he's super creepy. Phil C. from Oklahoma said, Notice that the killings not only stop after the trial, but also after Gabe goes back to Florida. But not only do they stop when Gabe leaves, they didn't start until Gabe arrived in Scranton. I would definitely be investigating Gabe if I were the Scranton police. But I'm not done. How about David Wallace?
我觉得加布是扼杀狂的可能性要大得多。众所周知，他喜欢暴力和恐怖。他在斯克兰顿和佛罗里达之间旅行，这使得他很容易躲避警察。而且他超级诡异。来自俄克拉荷马州的菲尔·C说：注意，谋杀案不仅在审判结束后停止了，而且在加布回到佛罗里达后也停止了。不仅在加布离开时停止，而且直到加布来到斯克兰顿才开始。如果我是斯克兰顿警察，我一定会调查加布。但我还没说完。大卫·华莱士怎么样？
Izzy S. from Surrey, England said, I recently found out some people believe David Wallace might be the Scranton Strangler. Apparently he sent Holly away just as she was getting close to figuring it out. Approach the bench. What? When was Holly investigating the Scranton Strangler? I don't know. Nevermind. Objection sustained.
来自英国萨里的伊兹·S说：我最近发现有人认为大卫·华莱士可能是斯克兰顿扼杀狂。显然，就在霍莉快要查出真相时，他把她支走了。反对。什么？霍莉什么时候调查过斯克兰顿扼杀狂？我不知道。算了。反对有效。
Sorry Izzy. I liked your argument. All right. Tyson H from Salt Lake City, Utah said this. At the writer's block panel at the Rap Party in Scranton, Greg Daniels. Greg Daniels said, wait, we can quote Greg Daniels, but we can't quote Paul Lieberstein. Your Honor.
对不起，伊兹。我很喜欢你的论点。好吧。来自犹他州盐湖城的泰森·H是这么说的。在斯克兰顿杀青派对的编剧座谈会上，格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，等等，我们可以引用格雷格·丹尼尔斯的话，但我们不能引用保罗·利伯斯坦的话，法官大人。
Continue. Well, I think this is biased. I got fast and loose. She gets continue. You're not going to contempt to court here. Calm down. Greg Daniels said, if the Scranton Strangler was anyone else, it would be none other than Robert
请继续。嗯，我觉得这很不公平。她说话随心所欲。她就能继续。你今天可别在这儿蔑视法庭。冷静点。格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，如果斯克兰顿扼杀狂是别人，那绝对非罗伯特·加利福尼亚莫属。
California. And my friends, if anyone possesses the four D's of deviance, distress, dysfunction, and danger. Is it not Robert California? I have given you three very good other suspects and one that maybe we're gonna throw out, but I still have one more.
我的朋友们，如果有人具备反社会、痛苦、功能失调和危险这“四D”特征，难道不是罗伯特·加利福尼亚吗？我已经给你们提出了三个非常好的其他嫌疑人，还有一个可能我们要排除，但我还有一个。
Jacqueline R. from Orange County, California, wrote in to say that she believes Moe's is the Scranton Strangler. The evidence, though circumstantial, forms a chilling mosaic of behavior, opportunity, and motive. It's very well written. Yeah, Jacqueline maybe should have written my whole thing. She was great. It's nice. I know. Jacqueline goes on to say, first, Moe's peculiar and antisocial behavior places him outside of societal norms where many criminal profiles of serial offenders begin. He is almost entirely isolated from society, living on a remote beet farm with limited
来自加州橙县的杰奎琳·R来信说，她相信莫斯就是斯克兰顿扼杀狂。这些证据虽然是间接的，却构成了一幅令人毛骨悚然的行为、机会和动机交织的拼图。写得非常好。是的，杰奎琳也许应该写我的整篇辩词。她太棒了。真不错。我知道。杰奎琳接着说，首先，莫斯古怪且反社会的行为使他脱离了社会规范，许多连环杀手的犯罪心理画像都是从这里开始的。他几乎完全与社会隔离，住在一个偏远的甜菜农场里，除了他的表弟德怀特之外，几乎没有人类互动。
human interaction except for his cousin Dwight. Anascara crew. Thank you for making my point, Angela. Moe's demonstrates signs of emotional instability, extreme awkwardness, and a lack of understanding of social boundaries, traits commonly associated with individuals capable of heinous crimes. I was meaning he loved a scarecrow,
和一个纪录片摄制组。谢谢你帮我指出这一点，安吉拉。莫斯表现出情绪不稳定、极度笨拙以及缺乏对社会界限的理解的迹象，这些特征通常与能够犯下滔天罪行的人有关。我的意思是，他喜欢稻草人，就像他对待她以及类似的事情一样。哦，我知道你是什么意思。而且我想杰奎琳也知道你是什么意思。安吉拉，这是你的论点吗？你觉得一个喜欢稻草人的家伙……另外，我太抱歉了。刚才谁在另一个人说话时默默记笔记？又是谁每四句话就要插话一次？
like he did her and stuff. Oh, I know what you meant. And I think Jacqueline knows what you meant. Angela, is this your argument? You think someone who does a scarecrow? Also, I'm so sorry. Who quietly took notes while the other person was talking? And who is breaking in every four sentences?
我很抱歉。有一长段时间我在听，然后我决定插话。你提到了几点。好吧，我继续说。莫斯有古怪而反常的行为，这些都是有案可查的，比如他喜欢跟在行驶的车辆旁边奔跑，无缘无故地尖叫，并且对肢体冲突表现出不自然的兴趣，正如他在与农场动物和同事摔跤时所看到的那样。
I am sorry. There was a long period where I listened, and then I decided to break in. You had a few things. Okay, I'm going on. Moe's has odd erratic behavior which has been well documented, such as his proclivity for running alongside moving vehicles, screaming without provocation, and displaying an unnatural interest in physical conflict as seen during his wrestling of farm animals and coworkers.
第二，莫斯的体格和接触勒死工具的机会使他成为一个可信的嫌疑人。他在农场里日常使用的工具——绳索、铁链和其他器具——与潜在的勒死工具惊人地相似。杰奎琳，你做得太棒了。对吧，对吧，你明白为什么我要以杰奎琳作为结案陈词了吧。第三也是最确凿的一点，
Second, Moses' physicality and access to tools of strangulation make him a credible suspect. The tools he uses daily on the farm, ropes, chains, other implements, are eerily similar to the potential instruments used in strangulations. Jacqueline, you are doing a fantastic job. Right, right, you see why I'm ending with Jacqueline here. Third and most damning,
莫斯既有作案机会，又与这些罪行近在咫尺。斯克兰顿距离施鲁特农场不远，偏远的地理位置为躲避嫌疑的人提供了完美的藏身之所。虽然纪录片摄制组专注于德怀特的活动，但莫斯的行踪往往无法追踪，这给了他充足的机会在不引起怀疑的情况下犯下这些滔天罪行。
Moe's had both the opportunity and proximity to carry out these crimes. Scranton is not far from Shroot Farms and the rural locations offers the perfect hideout for someone evading suspicion. While the documentary crew focused on Dwight's activities, Moe's whereabouts were often unaccounted for, giving him ample opportunity to commit these heinous acts
他能够作为一名古怪但无害的农场工人融入背景，这为他提供了便利，使他能够在不被注意的情况下行事。总之，我要引用加利福尼亚州穆尔帕克的阿里·W的话，她说：女士们，不。托比不是扼杀狂。他唯一的罪行就是既可悲又无趣，还把他的巴巴甘努什（茄泥酱）扔进办公室的垃圾桶。谢谢你们听我说完。
without raising suspicion. His ability to blend into the background as a peculiar but harmless farmhand works to his advantage, allowing him to operate unnoticed. In conclusion, I'd like to quote Ali W. from Moorpark, California who says, ladies, no. Toby is not the strangler. His only crime is being pathetic and uninteresting and throwing out his baba ganoush in the office trash. Thank you for your time.
说得太好了。说得太好了。谢谢，谢谢。现在我们怎么反驳卡西，谁先反驳？你看，你刚刚说过了，所以你应该反驳安吉拉，反过来也一样。所以我现在必须先说。
That was very good. That was very good. Thank you, thank you. Now how do we rebuttal Cassie, who goes first on the rebuttal? See, you just went, so you should rebuttal Angela and then vice versa. So I have to go first now.
对，基本上就是如果她提出了什么你想推翻的观点或者你有证据，那就是你要重点关注的。好吧，那我会这么说。好的。安吉拉，这是我对你论点的反驳。好的。你描绘了一幅很有趣的画面，为什么……
Yeah, and basically like if there is any points she made that you wanna like take down or you have evidence, that would be what you would focus on. Okay, then I will say this. Okay. Here is my rebuttal, Angela, to your arguments. Okay. You paint an entertaining picture of why.
为什么听起来像是在评判别人？托比是斯克兰顿扼杀狂，但这全都是基于间接证据，我相信我在论点中已经证明了，如果我们愿意的话，可以用同样的标准把邓德米弗林世界的许多人都描绘成这样。但你的所有论据在法庭上都根本站不住脚。离婚、创伤发生在我们很多人身上。难道我们都是连环杀手吗？安吉拉·K，你喜欢幻想。你是个连环杀手吗？嗯。还有，住在温哥华。你提到了护照。我提到托比的指纹会记录在那本护照上。我们知道现场留下了指纹，而且与托比不符，但它们与乔治·霍华德·斯库布的指纹相符。我知道，安吉拉，你提到过你相信，除了勒死所有人，同时过着主要由纪录片摄制组记录的生活之外，托比还有时间谋杀别人并陷害另一个男人。
Why does that sound judgy? Toby is the Scranton Strangler, but it's all based on circumstantial evidence and I believe I proved in my argument that we could paint a number of people in the world of Dunder Mifflin with that same brush if we wanted. But none of your arguments really hold up in court. Divorce, trauma happens to a lot of us. Are we all serial killers? Angela Kay, you love fantasy. Are you a serial killer? Hmm. Also, live in Vancouver. You mentioned the passport. I mentioned that Toby's fingerprints would be on record for said passport. We know that fingerprints were left behind and they do not match Toby, but they do match George Howard Scubb. And I know, Angela, you mentioned that you believe perhaps in addition to strangling everyone while living a life mostly documented by a documentary crew,
你在暗示也许是托比给乔治·霍华德·斯库布提供了这辆车？真的吗？乔治·霍华德·斯库布在接受警方审讯时，不想提这件事吗？他不想说这辆车我是从别人那里弄来的之类的话吗？我觉得我们所有人都应该承认，警方抓对了人，那个人就是乔治·霍华德·斯库布。谢谢。嗯，精彩的反驳。这是我的反驳。我从这里开始。你提到过，根据FBI的说法，连环杀手不珍视人命。我会对你说，托比有一种人格，他可以把人割裂开来，对于那些本该有价值的人，他完全看不到他们的价值。我举个例子，他为了去帕姆的艺术展，竟然愿意抛弃他难得见一面的女儿。我再举个例子，他决定抛下女儿去哥斯达黎加。托比能够进行心理隔离。你提到了氡气中毒。难道这不会是托比最终干掉我们所有人的方式吗？
Toby had time to murder people and frame another man. You're suggesting that maybe Toby provided George Howard Scubb with this car? Really? George Howard Scubb didn't want to mention that? He didn't want to say I got this car from someone else or anything like that when he was being interrogated by police? I think we all need to just admit the police caught the right person and that person is George Howard Scubb. Thank you. Well, fantastic rebuttal. Here's my rebuttal. I will start with this. You mentioned, according to the FBI, serial killers do not value human life. I would
我想指出的是，拥有这类人格的人，他们共同的主要特征之一就是对事物极度痴迷。氡气、帕姆、当陪审团成员，他们锁定某样东西，然后陷入死循环，并以非常黑暗的方式表现出来。你提到了指纹，说托比的指纹在他的护照上，它们不可能出现在犯罪现场，而乔治的指纹在那里。但我们从托比本人那里了解到，他曾研究过如何利用别人的指纹来实施犯罪。他亲自分享过他如何研究这个课题并在他的一本书中写到了这一点。你和杰奎琳提出了令人信服的论点，讨论了谁还可能犯下这些罪行，但他们都没有托比那样的动机。他们都没有那种拒绝、痛苦、嫉妒和霸凌。托比的愤怒在 annex（附楼）里静静地酝酿，并以斯克兰顿扼杀狂的形式爆发出来。
say to you, Toby has a personality where he can compartmentalize people and have no value at all to people who should have value. I will cite the moment when he is willing to ditch his daughter who he barely sees to go to Pam's art show. I will cite the moment where he decides to leave his daughter to go to Costa Rica. Toby can compartmentalize. You brought up the radon poisoning. Wouldn't that be the way Toby would finally get us all?
托比就是斯克兰顿扼杀狂。不要怀疑，因为如果你怀疑了，他也会把你耍得团团转。哦，哇。这就是我的反驳。我想接下来我们要做的就是休息一下，回来和保罗·利伯斯坦好好聊聊这件事。对，这真的很有趣。我同意。
I would like to point out that people that have these type of personalities, one of the main things they have in common is extreme obsessions with things. Radon, Pam, being on this jury, they lock into something and they get into a loop and it manifests itself in very dark ways. You mentioned the fingerprints, that Toby's fingerprints are on his passport, that they couldn't be at the scene of
音乐：好的，我们回来了。保罗·利伯斯坦，也就是托比，来到现场了。欢迎来到法庭，托比。哦，好吧。你应该知道，我们在这里展开了一场相当激烈的辩论。我们非常高兴能听到你的看法。我们能从一点背景故事开始吗？可以，当然可以。好的。
the crime, that George's fingerprints are there, passport, that they couldn't be at the scene of the crime, that George's fingerprints are there. But we learn from Toby himself that he has studied how you can use other people's fingerprints to implement them in a crime. He literally shared that he studied on how to do this and wrote about it in one of his books. You make compelling arguments along with Jacqueline about who else could have done these crimes, but none of them had the motive that Toby had. None of them had the rejection, the bitterness, the jealousy, the bullying. Toby's rage is simmering quietly in the annex and it comes out in the form of the Scranton Strangler.
好的。保罗，给你的第一个问题，来自……对，没错。保罗，给你的第一个问题来自费城发信的凯利·W。哦，这是一场正式的辩论。这是一场严肃的辩论，保罗。好吧，那我为我的态度道歉。法官大人，能记下他的态度吗？这已经记录在案了。是的，我希望你不是个充满敌意的证人。我可能会被当作充满敌意的证人对待。好吧。好吧，好吧。我已经习惯了。
Toby is the Scranton Strangler. Don't doubt it, because if you do, he will have fooled you too. Oh, wow. That's my rebuttal. I think all that's left is for us to take a break and come back and talk with Paul Lieberstein all about it. Yeah, this was really fun. I agree.
啊。托比，这就是我身上的托比。这就是那个托比。啊。好吧，这是你的第一个问题。来自宾夕法尼亚州费城的凯利·W问：谁最初提出了斯克兰顿扼杀狂的点子？他一直都是一个常驻角色或故事线，还是这只是随着剧集的发展自然而然演变成的一个持续的笑话？给我们讲讲背景吧。所以，这很难追溯。哦，汤米！我试过了。这是一个谜。不，确实是个谜。所以，有很大可能是我的主意，
Music Alright, we are back. Paul Lieberstein, aka Toby, is here. Welcome to the courtroom, Toby. Oh, well. You should know that we have entered into quite a hot debate here. We are very excited to get your perspective. Can we start with a little backstory? We can, sure. All right.
但我不能确定。而且我一直在联系其他人。所以它最早出现在查理的那集里。那就像是一个背景笑话，婴儿那一集。是的。但他不记得自己写过这个。报纸头条。对，没错。
Yeah. First question for you, Paul, from Kelly W. in right, yeah. First question for you Paul from Kelly W. in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. Oh, this is a formal debate. This is a serious debate, Paul. All right, well I apologize for my attitude. Your Honor, can his attitude be noted? It's on the books. Yes, I hope you aren't a hostile witness. I may be treated like a hostile witness. All right. OK, all right. I'm used to it.
我们只是想要个梗，你知道的，因为人们总是送那种婴儿礼物。所以我们只是想要个不太合时宜的梗。没错，从“春天来了”变成了“扼杀狂再次出击”。所以我问格雷格这是否是他的主意，因为我知道他深度参与了那一集的重写。
Aw. Toby, that's the Toby in me. That's the Toby. Aw. Well, here's your first question. Kelly W. from Philadelphia, Pennsylvania said, who originally had the idea for the Scranton Strangler? Was he always going to be a recurring character or storyline, or was this something that became a continuous joke
他觉得是我的主意。哦。然后我又问了其他一些当时在场的、似乎很喜欢这个点子的人，包括几个编剧助理，还有丹尼、B·J和霍尔斯特德，他们似乎都觉得是我的。好吧。这一个笑话是你的主意。但沃伦说他也觉得是你的。对，但我不能确定。而且我可不想掠美他人。
through the series just sort of organically? Give us the background. So, it's difficult to trace this. Oh, Tommy! I have tried. It's a mystery. No, it is. So, there's a decent chance it was my idea,
你太善良了，保罗。我是说，大多数编剧都认为是你的。但你还是觉得：可能不是我。所以听起来有点像是我的。虽然听起来也挺像明迪的。但这个最初在拍摄时被打算作为一个一次性的搞笑梗。是的，本来没打算搞那么大。好吧。但就像很多事情一样，它慢慢发展壮大了。
but I can't say for sure. And I've been contacting people. So it first appeared in Charlie's episode. It was like a background joke, the baby episode. Yes. But he didn't remember writing it. The newspaper headline. Yeah, exactly.
是的。是的，不过我想再次记录在案，为了记录：在构思的时候，这真的只是一个报纸上的笑话。谢谢。已记录在案。安吉拉，你想问第二个问题吗？我想问，而且我不觉得你刚才要求记录在案的东西能证明什么，不过好吧。保罗。是的，安吉拉。你知道人们觉得托比是斯克兰顿扼杀狂吗？是的。所以来自英国的艾登·B问：保罗是有意地编写、扮演这个角色，还是计划让它像现在这样模棱两可？比如，托比到底是不是斯克兰顿扼杀狂？是的，我也对这个很好奇。
And we just wanted something, you know, because people always get that gift for a baby. So we just wanted like an inappropriate. Right, it went from spring has sprung to the grand strangler strikes again. So I asked Greg if it was his, because I know that he got very involved in the rewrite of that episode.
你们是什么时候意识到粉丝们开始怀疑托比就是斯克兰顿扼杀狂的？是在我们还在播出的期间吗？没有，是在我们杀青之后。我看过那个关于把线索拼凑起来的YouTube视频，那是第一个说可能是托比的视频，这让我大开眼界。现在有很多这样的视频了。
And he thought it was mine. Oh. And then I asked a bunch of other people who seemed to like it and who were around at the time, including a couple of writer assistants, and Danny and BJ and Halstead, and they seemed to think it was mine. Okay. This one joke was your idea. But Warren said he thought it was yours as well. Yeah, but I can't say for sure. And I would hate to be taking credit for someone else's pitch.
对，有很多。我为了这个播客看了一堆。而且都很长。因为有大量证据证明他是。对其他角色也是如此。对吧？是的，对于其他可能是斯克兰顿扼杀狂的角色，YouTube上有大量的分析。嗯——哼。再次指出这一点。不，我以前从没想过可能会是我。我们可能开过一些可能是克里德的玩笑。我们可能开过那种玩笑。克里德。我们可能开过那种玩笑。
You're so kind, Paul. I mean, the majority of the writers think it was you. But you're still like, it might not be me. So it kind of sounds like me. Although it also sounds like Mindy too. But this was intended to be originally a one-off joke gag in the delivery. Yeah, it hadn't been for more than that. Okay. But it kind of grew as things do.
克里德确实过着很多种不同的人生。是的。是的，我想这在第九季中表现得非常强烈。是的。但那是你在最后才能做的那种事。我猜是的。而且克里德，我不知道，他存在于一个完全不同的层面。他很喜欢这个主意。他喜欢自己就是斯克兰顿扼杀狂这个主意。而且如果不是因为乔治的话，托比可能是所有人都会把罪名扣在上面的那个人。好吧，我们的下一个问题是这样的。明迪说，斯克兰顿扼杀狂是编剧室里被提出过最多的点子之一。
Yeah. Yes. But I would like to note for the record, again for the record, when conceived this was simply a newspaper joke. Thank you. Committed to record. Angela, would you like to ask question number two? I would and I don't think what you're committing to record proves anything but okay. Paul. Yes Angela. You are aware that people think Toby is the Scranton Strangler. Yes. So Aiden B from the UK says did Paul purposely write or play the role or plan for it to be as ambiguous as it is? Like is Toby the Scranton Strangler? Yeah, I'm curious about that too.
她说，如果你把所有的笔记整理起来，你会得到一部史诗般且令人毛骨悚然的迷你剧。你还记得你们当时讨论过哪些点子吗？不，我觉得大部分都是这种：这个人被勒死了。你知道的，你在寻找——我们在寻找故事中的转折。所以就像我们在黑板上列了这张清单，对吧？
When did you all become aware that fans were keying into Toby being the Scranton Strangler? Was it while we were still on the air? No, it was after we wrapped. So I watched that YouTube video about putting together, the very first one that said it might be Toby, and it kind of blew my mind. There are many now.
在写完剧情后，比如我们有没有加入一个触发事件？哦，没有。你知道的，这就像是故事里很简单的东西。其中之一就是一个转折，你知道吗？这是一个直奔结局的故事，还是说，你知道的，我们在这方面做点文章？
Yeah, there are a lot. And I watched a bunch for this podcast. And they were long. Because there's a lot of evidence to prove that he is. And for other characters, too. Right? Yeah. Yes, for other characters
是的，有很多。为了这个播客我看了很多。而且它们都很长。因为有很多证据证明他是。还有其他角色的证据，对吧？是的，没错，对于其他角色
that could be the Scranton Strangler. There's a lot of YouTube out there. Mm-hmm. Pointing that out again. No, it had not crossed my mind that it could be, that it would be me. We may have jokes that could be Cree. We might have joked around like that. Cree. We might have joked around like that.
可能是斯克兰顿扼喉手。油管上有大量相关的视频。嗯哼。再次指出了这一点。不，我从未想过可能会是我，会是我本人。我们可能开过可能是克里（Cree）的玩笑。我们可能开过这样的玩笑。克里。我们可能开过这样的玩笑。
Cree definitely had a lot of different lives that he led. Yes. Yeah, which came out really strongly in season nine, I guess. Yes. But that's the kind of thing you can do in the very end. I guess. And Cree, I don't know, he existed
克里绝对过着许多截然不同的生活。是的。是的，这在第九季中表现得非常强烈，我想。是的。但这就是那种你可以在最后阶段做的事情。我猜。而且克里，我不知道，他存在于
on a whole different plane. And he loves the idea. He loves the idea that he was the Scranton Strangler. And that Toby is the one everyone would pin it on, maybe, if not for George. Well, our next question is this. Mindy said that the Scranton Strangler was one of the most pitched things in the writer's room.
一个完全不同的平面上。他很喜欢这个想法。他喜欢自己是斯克兰顿扼喉手这个主意。而且如果不是因为乔治的话，也许托比才是所有人都会把罪名安到头上的人。好吧，我们的下一个问题是这样的。敏迪说，斯克兰顿扼喉手是编剧室里最常被提出的点子之一。
She said that if you compiled all the notes, you would have an epic and terrifying mini-series. Do you remember any of the pitches that you guys had? No, I think it was a lot of just, this person gets strangled. You know, you're looking for, we're looking for a twist in the story. So like, we have this list up on the board, right?
她说，如果你把所有的笔记整理起来，你就会得到一部史诗般且吓人的迷你剧。你还记得你们当时提出的任何构思吗？不，我觉得很多都只是，这个人被扼杀了。你知道的，你在寻找，我们在寻找故事的转折。所以就像，我们在黑板上列了这张清单，对吧？
Of like, after we write things, like did we include an sighting incident? Oh no. You know, it's like, the simple things in stories. And so one of them was a twist, you know? Is it a straight line to the end or, you know, do we go somewhere with this?
就像，在我们写完东西之后，比如我们是否包含了一个诱发事件？哦，不。你知道的，这就像，故事里简单的事情。所以其中之一就是一个转折，你知道的？这是一条通往结局的直线，还是说，你知道的，我们要让这个情节走向何方？
Do you put in a twist? So I think a twist or like second outbreak commonly Is it a straight line to the end or, you know, do we go somewhere up with this? Do you put in a twist? So I think a twist or like second outbreak, commonly could be somebody gets strangled when we're really stretching. All right. Next question, sir. We also received a letter from Maria H. in Atlanta, Georgia, who said, have you heard the theory that the Scranton Strangler isn't a murderer?
Paul Eberstein famously posted a video on Instagram a few years ago saying that the writers of The Office always intended to include that the Scranton Strangler would just strangle his victims till they passed out, but never actually killed any of them. Now, I loved that. I thought that was super fun. I'm not sure everybody was on board for that.
But I loved it, just strangled them and left them there. Such a weird, passive, violent crime. I could kill you, but I'm not going to. But I'm not leaving you here. It's weirder, and then it becomes less of a crazy thing. I mean, it gets crazier, but in a way, it's just like, it's not a serial killer. Right, it's just a serial strangler?
It's just like, oh, that was a really bad night when I got strangled and passed out. And then what happened later? And then you live your life. You're gonna live the rest of your life. And he knows, he knows, like, I'm gonna take you live your life. You live the rest of your life. And he knows, he knows, like, I'm going to take you to the edge. Yeah, yeah, take you to the edge, yeah.
But then for Jordan. OK, sure, that's traumatic. I'm not saying there wouldn't be some therapy. But it's like, it's much smaller. So this was just an idea in the writer's room. This never, this fact never shows up on the show. It never shows up on the show. This idea.
No. Right. Which means it's not officially in the writer's room. This never, this fact never shows up on the show. It never shows up on the show. This idea. No. Right. Which means it's not officially in the lore, yes. And then also too, that would contradict George Howard Scubb getting the death penalty in life in prison, right? You're right. Because you don't strangle someone.
Your string of crimes, just stringing to passing out doesn't get you death penalty. Yeah, you're right. Wow, Angela. I feel like that is maybe. Unless. What? Unless he accidentally went too far one night and killed someone.
Right. Okay, so maybe that happened. You don't know it that. Yeah. Well, this leads us to one of our last questions, Paul, in our evidence gathering here. If you could go back and add one additional storyline for the Scranton Strangler, knowing everything you know now about all of the fan interest, maybe it would wrap things up, would you do it?
And if so, what would that thing be? No, I probably wouldn't wrap it up for the audience, but Scub getting out of prison, like say we had gone another 10 years. Okay. With Scub maybe getting out of prison and... Would Scub become Toby's friend that he'd always hoped for? Or Toby could be very, very scared. You know, or members of the jury could be very scared. You know, members of the jury could be very scared. Or there could be another strangling while Scubb was in prison.
Well, that would definitely fuel the fire. Yeah. And was it a copycat or did they get the wrong guy? Interesting questions. Yeah. We would do something like that. Yeah. It would have continued. Yeah, for sure. If we had continued. Yeah. And we would do something like that. Yeah. It would have continued. Yeah, for sure. If we had continued. This Grant and Strangler case was not over.
No, something like that isn't over, ever. Yeah. No. We're still talking about the Menendez brothers. True. True. Yeah. No, that would be the lore of the town
for as long as we documented that town and that community. Yeah, it's a big deal in the town, like, this grand size. Angela, do you have any more questions for Paul before we get to the question? No, I don't. I think, you know, we learned a lot about Toby today. We learned about his athleticism, how he could just hop a fence with no problem. I would also say that Toby has big hands, I noted. I'm so sorry, what is this? This is not the time for you to present more evidence. You're just rolling out evidence right now. What is this? You said to me, do you have anything else? I said, do you have any more questions for Paul? Okay. Not do you want to win because I won! This is one person's opinion. One person's opinion, it's Toby!
And by the way, what are the showrunners of The Office? So here's why he's not the scratcher. Oh, give it to us. All right, all right. Because we wouldn't do that. We're about like relatable office things. This fan theory doesn't exist in the realm of what would we normally do.
I'm saying this should be part of the theory. Part of the reason why he is not. Yes. Okay. Is you have to break the fourth wall and say the writers wouldn't do that. Well, okay, if you weren't breaking the fourth wall, then you would just say it's too unlikely. This is like an outcomes razor kind of thing. Like, no, the most likely thing is generally the truth, where the guy convicted is guilty of the thing.
Okay. You know, there was a trial. But yeah, if you're willing to break the fourth wall, and I've been thinking about this a lot over the last. Let's hear it. 24 hours of watching all those videos is just, well, you know, we always search for like the thing that people were experiencing,
which sometimes this is like a proximity to a big story, but not an actual part of it. So I feel like that would have been something we would have probably pitched, broken, we would have had a version of it, and ultimately decided like no this is not our show. Right this is not like we shouldn't do this this is a jump. This would be jumping the shark moment. Yeah for sure. If Dunder Mifflin had an employee that was a serial killer.
Yes. Okay so I guess that's my next question. Toby is not the Scranton Strangler. Does that mean that Creed, Robert California, Gabe, David Wallace, nobody is the Scranton Strangler. No one from our show. George Howard Scubb. No one in the world. Is the Scranton Strangler or was he wrongfully convicted? That maybe we don't know. Is the Strangler still out there?
That's a whole other question. Yeah, yeah. I mean mean people are wrongly convicted, right? Every once in a while. Once in a while. Okay. But generally, generally not. I don't know. Okay. Well maybe the cliffhanger here is is George Howard Scubb the Scranton Strangler or not? We may never know. We may never know. We officially mom detected of it.
What, Cassie? No, definitely never. Cassie's raising her hand. Angela, I wanna give you props for your debate, even though you lost. There was something you brought up that I kept thinking about, and you said that when George is driving the getaway car,
that car had been parked in the Dunder Mifflin parking lot before. Yes. Of course that's a production thing, but in the world of Scranton, I think that would be grounds for him to have an appeal. Cause what is that about? And then I also wondered of all of Scranton.
Wait, that could have been, he could have worked in the office park. But wouldn't we have known him then? Wouldn't we have known? Wouldn't we, I mean, we got so excited when the car chase went past our building, which is interesting because he clearly knows our street. Well that's what I was going to say, of all of Scranton. You know, there is some statistic, and I had it, but I don't have it with me now, that
a lot of times crimes are committed nearest where people live. And that's why a lot of times when people commit a crime near, close to where they live or work, they do a much harder job at trying to hide it because it's very close to their circle of where they live. So the fact that he drives down the street where his car is also parked, and while he's driving down the street where his car is also parked, and while he's driving down the street of all of Scranton,
that is where Dunder Mifflin is, and then Toby's phone rings as he's driving in that area, I think that did cause some suspicion about how is this person connected to the world of Dunder Mifflin. Yeah, the phone ring I don't get. I don't get how that points to Toby. I don't get how that points to Toby either.
Yeah. And then so maybe he stole a car from the office park since he lives in the area. So he definitely lives in the area, I think. So that car could potentially. But we know he lives in Scranton, so he's got to live somewhere. Yes.
And that car could belong to someone at Vance Refrigeration or any number of other people who work in the building. And so maybe he did steal the car. But I feel like we would have talked about that in the office, and maybe we did and the documentary crew didn't get it, but I think we would be like, oh my gosh, did you hear that such and such?
Leo's car from Vance Refrigeration was the one that the Scranton Strangler stole and drove down the street. Yeah, you'd think that would get around. That would get around. Yeah. Or, what? Maybe it was Bob Vance.
Oh no, don't reopen this can of worms. Maybe it was Bob Vance. Don't go there. He looks a little shady, like he could have some other things happening on the side. Shady, but that's different. I know. Yeah, I don't see it as bad.
I know, I know, I was just playing. I know you're playing. I know you're playing. Well, you don't think this is a real court of law. I think it is. Toby, Toby, I called you Toby. Where's the jury? Look around, look around. Paul, I took an online course.
I'm certified now. Where's the jury? I am certified. Do you see a jury in this room? I do. Okay. Sam and Cassie. Yeah, Cassie, I am curious.
Before Paul gave us the definitive answer and I won because I picked the right side, who were you gonna award the win to based on our debating? Yeah, you both had great arguments and everything. I do think Angela had the hardest job, but yeah, I would have given it to you, Jenna, because- To me, oh! I would have- I don't think Toby is the Scranton Strangler.
I will also say this, Jenna proudly said because I picked the right argument, we just said we both have to pick one. Jenna was like, I'll say that he isn't. I said, okay, fine. I'll say yes. Well, and I want to say I might have been awarded the win by both Paul and Cassie, but I would have awarded you the win because I thought your debate was just fantastic today. I really, really did.
I was like, oh no, I was sweating it when it was my turn. So I feel like we both won today. And you know who I really think won? The office Ladies community. Oh yeah, for sure. Really, really. And Paul, you're in studio with us. This is so fun.
I know. This is so great. Before you go, can you tell us about your project with Audible, your show, Middle Space? Oh yeah. I love this thing so much. I want people to listen to it. I want people to, as well.
Middle Space, all one word. But the full title is middle space colon the rebels attack and then the other side attacks as well And it is one of the Funnest silliest things I've ever done. Will you tell us sort of the world of it? Yes. So we're in space okay, let's call it the future I guess and Will Forte stars as this captain. Oh, he's so funny. Who starts off very early that they get a distress call,
and he decides not to go. Oh, not to take the distress call. Not to go. Doesn't he like it? He doesn't feel like it. He doesn't want to. And that's his reason he just doesn't want to. And that's his reason. He just doesn't want to. And he's that kind of captain.
And he just kind of wants to float around in space. And he's very interested in getting out of the space business, captaining business. He'd like to get into fast food. And goes around interviewing a manager of an intergalactic burger chain. But it is, you know, four and a half hours of not a single mission. It's just life in space. And it's very like anti-sci-fi. Oh, Jenna, you might like it.
I'm not a sci-fi fan, but I love this comedy spin on sci-fi. Like, it's a satirical take on sci-fi adventure. I have a question. It was really fun. It's a great cast. John Malkovich narrated. Oh my gosh. And we had a lot of great people in there.
I have one question. Yeah. Throughout the whole time where he's looking at how to become a fast food worker. Yeah. Are there more distress calls that come through that he just continues to ignore? Yes, he ignores all work goals. They would like to mutiny, but they're not quite capable of pulling that off because that takes a lot. It takes a lot of effort. Yeah. I mean, you got to kill someone.
They don't want to do that in the end. He might listen to Mel Robbins, who likes to remind us all the time that I don't want to is a perfectly acceptable reason to not do something. To not do something. And reigns in it. And he plays the rebel leader. Oh, great. And he calls up one of the people on the ship is in contact with the rebel leader. Clark. Clark Duke is in it.
Oh, Clark is in it. And Clark plays someone on the bridge who's very upset that we're not. Taking the distress calls. Taking the distress calls. Or really doing anything. He doesn just know what his life's about if he's not doing something so he gets in contact with a rebel leader and he calls him up and his son answers and and they have a great conversation and it's
played by Henry my son and we did it kind of like word by word. He was really young at the time. And it's so cute and so funny. I can't wait to hear that, Paul. I love that. Yeah. Well, we'll include all the information in our Insta stories and our website with links
so you guys can go and listen. That is so cool. And then Paul, just one last thing. You know, we've put a period at the end of the sentence of one fan theory, and I hate to open a window here on another. Oh, I see what you did there. But the last time we saw you,
所以你们可以去听听看。太酷了。保罗，最后还有一件事。你知道的，我们给一个粉丝理论画上了句号，但我讨厌在这个时候又打开另一扇窗。哦，我懂你刚才那个双关语。但是我们上次见到你时，
we discussed your particular pet peeve, which is that the windows of the Dunder Mifflin building, the interior and exterior windows do not match. Would you like a moment to speak to that? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because you're very passionate about this. I am. This fucked me so much and no one seemed to care at all. This is your radon.
我们讨论了你的一大死穴，那就是邓德米弗林大楼的窗户，内部和外部的窗户根本对不上。你想花点时间谈谈这个吗？对，对，对。因为你对此充满热情。我是认真的。这把我气得要死，但似乎根本没人介意。这就是你的氡气问题。
This is your radon. This is your radon. What radon was to Toby? These windows are to you. So we set the windows, obviously, in Culver City, right? When we were down there, we moved to the valley in season two. Outside of that building had those big, wide glass things. And then the inside of our windows
这就是你的氡气。这就是你的氡气。托比对氡气有多执着？这些窗户对你就有多执着。所以我们显然是在卡尔弗城搭景的，对吧？当我们搬到那里时，我们在第二季搬到了山谷。那个建筑的外景有那些巨大、宽敞的玻璃。然后我们室内的窗户
were these very small, kind of like three by six rectangular windows. There's no way they match. I mean, it's startling. And then the view from anybody's, any one window, we would change all the time depending on what we wanted to see. That's true. And that pissed me off so much too. It's just like, no, out that window has to be this one thing. And they're like, nope, it doesn't matter. And it doesn't matter.
却是那种非常小的、大约三乘六的矩形窗户。它们绝对不可能对得上。我的意思是，这太显眼了。然后从任何人的任何一扇窗户看出去的风景，我们总是根据想看到的内容随之改变。确实如此。这也把我气得够呛。就像是，不对，那扇窗户外必须是那个特定的景物。而他们却说，不，没关系。而且这根本不重要。
And then I broke it too. And we needed to kind of like see Michael hop a train. I picked that window to be outside. That's great. Yeah. You're part of the problem. to be outside, you know. That's great. Yeah. You're part of the problem. Part of the problem.
然后我还把它给弄坏了。我们需要拍迈克尔赶火车的画面。我挑了那扇窗户作为外景。太棒了。对啊。你也是问题的一部分。作为外景，你知道的。太棒了。对啊。你也是问题的一部分。问题的一部分。
Well, do you feel any better now that you've at least gotten to speak to it? I think at one point I was like, let's not, don't point the camera up. Don't see this building. Just keep it low. If people are going to freak out, it's not going to be okay. It's not the same windows.
好吧，既然你至少有机会把这话说出来了，有没有觉得好受点？我想我曾一度想说，咱们别这样，别把摄像机往上拍。别拍这栋楼。把镜头压低点。如果大家要抓狂的话，那可就糟了。这根本不是同一扇窗户。
And it's so clearly not the same windows. And then no one cared. They pointed up. I hope today there's someone listening out there, Paul, that was like, I always wondered about the windows. I just probably ruined the show for somebody. Well, Paul, thank you so much for joining us today. Thank you for having me on.
而且很明显它们就不是同一扇窗户。然后根本没人介意。他们还是往上拍了。我希望今天外面有人在听的时候会想，保罗，我一直对这些窗户很好奇。我可能刚刚把这部剧给某个人毁了。好吧，保罗，非常感谢你今天能来。谢谢邀请我来。
It's so good to see you guys. So good to see you too. And we have settled the fan theory is Toby the Scranton Strangler. Toby is not. Not. But we don't know who really is. Is it George?
见到你们真好。见到你们也很高兴。我们已经解决了那个粉丝理论——托比是不是斯克兰顿扼杀狂。托比不是。不是。但我们不知道真正的凶手是谁。是乔治吗？
We don't know. We don't know. We can assume. Thank you everyone for listening to Office Ladies this week. We will see you next week with our super fan breakdown of The Fire. Yes, and you guys be sure and check out Paul's audible show Middle Space.
我们不知道。我们不知道。我们可以猜想一下。谢谢大家本周收听《办公室女士》。下周我们将为您带来《大火》的超级粉丝深度解析。是的，大家一定要去看看保罗的有声书节目《中间空间》。
And we'll see you next week. See you then. Bye everyone. That was very, very white. That was very, very white. But it was. It was. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela
我们下周见。到时候见。大家再见。这真的很白人。这真的很白人。但确实是。是的。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西
Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。Odyssey 的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。